they shelled a house uh where these uh  men were sheltering uh and then after  that there was an exchange of gunfire  after which these two men were shot  there 19 other people wounded as well  both abdul rahman saw and the other  young man that was killed during this  attack were part of the  fatah  military wing which is called the  al-aqsa  martyrs brigade  israeli acting prime minister yay lapid  has just tweeted is that uh the israeli  forces  raided the hideouts of wanted people in  nablus tonight these are terrorists who  recently carried out a series of  shooting attacks  people that we've been talking to today  have said that they feel that there's no  security here these raids could take  place at any moment and that they also  could be at risk since the start of  this year in the occupied territories  there have been more than 70 people  killed  [Music]  [Music]  you